is a highly charged issue this obviously
one that throws up very big important
social moral and ethical questions and
there are strong emotions on display
here outside Court when the Judgment was
handed down Heidi uh this she's 27 years
old she has Down syndrome she lives
independently she brought this challenge
to the law because in her view the law
is discriminatory it allows babies with
severe fetal abnormalities including
Down syndrome to be aborted right up
until birth whereas normally the time
limit for abortions is 24 weeks into a
pre into a pregnancy in a Heidi crowd's
view that law is discriminatory and and
in her view it stereotypes a person a
life of a disabled person is a life not
worth living so she wanted that law to
be changed that law to be that part of
the abortion act to be removed but
judges here at the court of appeal ruled
against uh upholding the law as lawful
in their view the law is not unlawful as
it has to strike a balance between the
rights of a pregnant woman and the
rights of an unborn child and and they
said that the question of whether it
should be lawful is not a question for
the courts to decide it's one for
Parliament to decide now I'm actually
joined by Heidi now along with her
husband James and her mother Liz uh
Heidi
um first of all thanks for speaking to
us and what is your reaction to this
ruling well my first reaction was I was
absolutely just thought and the reason
why they said that my views don't matter
when it does
because I'm someone who has dancing game
why did you want to bring the the the
challenge in the first place why do you
want that law changed how does it make
you feel the fact that that is law it
makes me feel like the eyes didn't be
here but I should be extinct
I know there's not two but um that's how
it makes me feel and the other day when
I was holding my let me ribbon
in Exeter I was
protects him and not me
and what will you do now will you will
you appeal again to take the case to the
court of the Supreme Court yes
yes you're not giving up no and and in
the Judgment there as I just mentioned
the the the judge said that this this
question of whether it should be lawful
this part of the law is not one for the
courts it's a question for Parliament I
mean at least perhaps he can answer this
what what's your message to MPS will he
take it to start a campaign it's
obviously be discussing everything with
our solicitor what's right with Heidi
solicitor
um and we'll go to the Supreme Court but
if we um an MP would like to take the
case up we're more than happy to meet
them and get on with it um work with
anybody that would have to get the law
changed but that's the best way to do it
that's the way we'll do it
and how do you feel what's your reaction
to today's ruling this absolutely
um
that's right up into the moment of birth
a baby with a disability can be born
even though five minutes later after
birth they have all the protection of
any other person but in the in the womb
they have no protection
and my my second claimants can't be here
today but when they see what a thing
that with her son she wasn't talking
repeatedly to have one but as he said to
have have an abortion yeah well if he
says in her nose
he said she didn't want to divorce yeah
and they still kept on
so they tried to persuade her to have an
abortion this week yeah at 30 at 36
weeks They carried on persuading him
persuading her to try and have an
abortion she decided against that okay
well thank you very much thanks for
speaking to us um and good luck with
your campaign um clearly that they're
going to continue their campaign
um and take it all the way to the
Supreme Court after losing this latest
round to change the law that allows
babies with Down Syndrome to be aborted
right up until birth